for now we're going to turn to the
upcoming election and two important
Senate races that could decide who
controls congress come January Edo keeps
his tracking the Senate debate in Ohio
but first we're going to go to Nicole
Killian in Atlanta where Senate
candidate Herschel Walker is getting
help today from two notable Republican
Senators Nicole good morning to you what
are we learning
hey good morning to you Tony and this is
all about trying to shore up the
candidacy of Herschel Walker and what is
arguably one of the most pivotal Senate
races to decide control of Congress
Senators Rick Scott of Florida and Tom
Cotton of Arkansas will appear with the
embattled as Senate Republican candidate
in a campaign stop here outside of
Atlanta today Walker who says he
supports an abortion ban without
exceptions has been dogged by
allegations that he paid for an
ex-girlfriend's abortion more than a
decade ago he has denied those
allegations in a statement Senator Rick
Scott also chairs the campaign armed for
Senate Republicans said that he is on
herschel's team and is proud to stand
with him of course this all comes as the
former football star is set to debate
Democratic senator Rafia Warnock later
this week Tony
looking forward to watching that I know
you are as well Nicole thank you very
much